now Simon Clark was one of Liz truss's
closest allies so he had a ringside seat
at the formation of the economic policy
that was to bring her down he backed
Boris Johnson initially in the contest
to replace her so he was quickly out as
leveling up secretary when Rishi sunak
took the top job he's also been Chief
Secretary of the Treasury and criticized
the signs of the state so what does he
want to see from the chancellor on
Thursday thank you very much for being
on the program this morning at Mr Clark
I'm not sure if you managed to catch any
of Jeremy Hunter interview but he did
say that we can all expect to be paying
a bit more tax do you think he's got the
right approach
uh yes I think it is absolutely right
that we balance the books I would urge
Jeremy to make sure that we do as much
as we can from spending reductions as
opposed to tax increases noting that
clearly taxes at a very high level and
faced with the recession risk that we
all know uh exists at the moment I I
think the balance of advantage and the
best pro-growth option would be to
reduce spending rather than to increase
taxes but I recognize he's got a
incredibly difficult job to do and he
will have my support in making sure that
we strike an arrangement which will give
the markets confidence and the country
confidence that we can pay our way in
the world
you say that you'd like to see the
balance slightly tipped in favor of
spending reductions at the same time
though a lot of Public Services are
already under pretty deep strain whether
it's you know the NHS whether it's
schools whether it's defense are there
any areas where there are more
efficiency savings if you like to be
found
my I think the main thing is I would say
that we should protect the defense
budget at a time when obviously the
world is in turmoil when we're seeing
the effects of Putin's war and when we
know that China is keeping an eye firmly
on what opportunities may exist for her
with Taiwan so I would urge him not to
cut the defense budget and to stick by
Liz's three percent commitment of GDP by
the end of the decade but beyond that I
think there are areas where we can make
savings I think that our capital
investment programs are significantly
over committed I think there is a real
issue with underspends across a lot of
government because of the impact of
covert and as a result there is the
potential there to realize tens of
billions of savings without cutting
crucially vital Public Services
at the same time though aren't those
kind of capital product projects quite
important for growth
well some of them can be I mean
obviously some of them don't need to be
necessarily cut they can be canceled uh
but they can also be deferred in terms
of the time scale for these projects so
it doesn't necessarily need to be the
case that you uh end them entirely but
you can say that we'll reprofile them in
terms of when they will come on stream
and that offers obviously considerable
savings potential I think something like
hs2 obviously we've seen rail passenger
numbers have not recovered to
pre-pandemic levels particularly for
commuter travel there are real questions
about schemes like this which I think
ought to be addressed first before we
cut things like defense before we cut
things obviously which really matter to
the public and I think that is the the
challenge obviously that Jeremy has to
face but my own view is having obviously
spent uh most of the last year as Chief
Secretary of the Treasury the the
opportunity in this statement is really
to reprofile our Capital spend so that
we can we can get to a better a more
sustainable place I really would urge
him to be very careful about cutting
some of the things though which would go
to the heart of our national security
um I want to talk a bit about tax Rises
because it was pretty clear that there
are going to be a significant tax Rises
next week whether it's more High earners
paying the 45p rate whether it's
millions of people being effectively
paying more tax because of freezers to
income levels now Ian Duncan Smith told
Sky News that if the government tries to
hammer us too hard with tax Rises they
will actually drive us deeper into
recession do you agree with that
well one of the reasons uh clearly as I
supported Liz in the summer was that I
believe very strongly that you know with
the tax burden it's a 70-year high we
need to be extremely careful about about
further increasing the challenges facing
businesses and households and you know
that is something which I know Jeremy is
an entrepreneur will be very conscious
of I'm not saying there are easy answers
here and I certainly don't want to
uh to try to to sort of try and suggest
that the chancellor is is is is faced
with uh with with straightforward
options but what I do think is that we
we have throughout this exercise to be
incredibly aware of just how much we've
asked of both the British public and
British industry ever recent years
obviously corporation tax is going to go
up from 19 to 25 that's a heck of an
increase I think family budgets are
obviously as we all know under great
pressure because of the impact of the
inflation arising from the war in
Ukraine I would therefore as I say
strongly urge that the great balance of
this statement should come from spending
reductions because I really do think
that uh there is there is an issue with
our raising uh the burden of Taxation on
Britain at this time
now there's been a huge change of
Direction since the list trust
Administration that of course you were
such a key at part of on individual
policies such as the 45p rate of tax but
also on the general philosophy as well
you know Liz trust wanted to borrow to
fund growth Jeremy Hunt and Rishi sunak
are all about you know raising the tax
burden and cutting spending in order to
bring down um the deficit even in a
recession is there a risk do you think
that we're now swinging too far the
other way to overcompensate for what
came before
well look I mean I I think it is
absolutely imperative that we restore
Market confidence in this country and
it's it is it is it is right that the
government uh makes this statement this
week and shows a clear path to make our
our debt sustainable we've we've been
through an extraordinary series of
events uh the government has acted
rightly uh to make sure that we protect
British households but we have uh as a
result got ourselves into a what is a
very difficult situation and one which
is obviously shared by most other uh
Western economies have also had to act
uh to protect uh households and
businesses I do think that in this
exercise but we must be careful not to
choke off growth that would be my main
my main argument I don't dispute the
need uh to restore Market confidence I
think it's very important that we do set
out a clear a clear Runway three years
ahead but as I say I think I think that
if we're if if you're faced with two
difficult choices the better choice is
to curb public spending let's not forget
that government spending as a whole has
risen from
700 billion in 2010 when the
conservatives came to office to over a
trillion pounds today so it has risen
very substantially over the course of
the last decade there is the potential
there I believe to make savings which
don't damage public services and which
fundamentally allow us to achieve the
results that we need to uh while also
allowing a pro-growth policy to to be
delivered
now I've got to ask this because I feel
like many people listening to you will
be asking you know this question you you
were part of the Liz truss core team the
quad if you like and that was the team
that effectively you know trashed the
economy the bank of England had to step
in after the budget the chancellor was
let go the Prime Minister became the
shortest serving ever prime minister uh
in the UK
why should people listen to what you
have to say
well I I I would reject the idea that uh
what's happened in the economy is
primarily uh the result of what of the
actions that Liz took the the reality is
that a third of the global economy is
now in recession we are faced with
extraordinary headwinds uh coming out of
the situation in Ukraine which has
driven inflation to levels uh which we
haven't seen in my lifetime that
obviously comes on top of the legacy of
the pandemic not just the debt that we
incurred but also the uh the enormously
challenging Society of and economic
consequences that we're still feeling uh
and and interest rates are rising the
world over as a result I completely
accept uh that mistakes were made with
the timing of the mini budget and whilst
I take my share of responsibility as one
of Liz's cabinet ministers I I obviously
wasn't directly uh the the driver of
some of the choices that were made about
whether or not to hold a new spending
review for example which was something
that I had urged during the summer which
I I understood was the basis of the the
action that would be taken but look
nonetheless I do not resile from the
fundamental proposition that Liz set out
which is that this economy our society
as a whole needs to become more
economically Dynamic more successful if
we are to sustain the Public Services on
which people rely and to pay our way in
a world where frankly the West needs to
be more competitive if we're to keep up
with emerging emerging economies that
was Liz's fundamental Insight I think it
is right I think it is very important
that as the government seeks to address
the undoubted challenges that the UK
economy faces that we don't do things
that cut across that fundamental Mission
which is that our country needs to be a
successful place to operate a business
to grow
businesses large and small and that that
will not happen in the burden of
Taxation continues to increase
um of course equating
um the former Chancellor of course under
Liz truss gave an interview this week
where he says that he warned Liz truss
about going too fast is that your
recollection of things
well I I obviously wasn't privy to the
individual conversations between Liz and
quasi and it's it's not really for me to
interpose myself into the discussion of
who said what when I have the greatest
respect for both Liz and for quasi and I
think the way events have played out
obviously uh it has it perhaps been
somewhat reductive uh and somewhat
caricatured in terms of the positions
that that were adopted as I say I
believe there would be a full spending
review to a company uh the the tax cuts
that Liz wanted to make I think that
would have been the way of showing the
markets that we wanted to transition to
a lower tax more Dynamic economy but
that we had a clear plan to do so linked
to reductions in public spending that
was certainly the position that we had
discussed during the summer and I
believe it would have been a way of
making Liz's fundamental Mission more
sustainable uh and that that that is a
that is obviously a lasting regret uh
that I hold but do I think as I say that
what Liz was saying about growth remains
true I absolutely do and I have a lot of
respect for the courage that she showed
in trying to move the debate onto ground
which I think is essential for the
long-term health of our economy
when was the last time you spoke to you
less trust and how was she
uh well I I saw Liz at the the the
farewell Gathering that she held at
Checkers last month and I'm going to see
her again uh this week but she is
remarkably uh resilient she's always
been exceptionally dignified and there's
no there's no self-pity there there is
obviously regret and we all share uh
regret for what happened and uh you know
I I certainly uh continue to regard Liz
as both a a great colleague and a good
friend and someone who as I say I think
has fundamentally got her her
perspective on what this country needs
to do right uh we we obviously all uh
have to look back and learn the lessons
of what happened in the Autumn but
ought the message to go out that Britain
can should be a high tax High regulation
economy as labor wants it to be and that
that is the route to success I'm afraid
uh that that is not true now it wasn't
true then and we have to be very careful
as we seek to balance the books in this
country that we do remember that
competitiveness internationally is the
watchword against which ultimately uh
all our actions ought to be judged okay
thank you uh very much indeed Simon
Clark there in t-site
thank you